Denis Daniels back in 2017 you filed a
lawsuit against Disney claiming that
they stole your idea for inside-out you
were in talks with Disney and Pixar for
years but then they refused the project
only to later revamp it and give you the
cold shoulder in the end Disney has the
best lawyers so we're not surprised that
you lost the case but sadly you're not
the only person this happened to Disney
has famously been accused of borrowing
ideas from their staff members and
competitors but it looks like stealing
ideas from those around them can be
traced all the way back to Walt Disney
himself keep watching to find out how a
reportedly stolen character led to Walt
Disney's fame and how his company has
continued to borrow ideas ever since
please call me Johnny fine Johnny you
have dickin name for yourself o choose
many things for myself
Pixar produced the animated film up in
2009 it was distributed by Walt Disney
and quickly became a hit racking in over
700 million dollars in gross revenue but
while everyone at Disney gave each other
Pat's on the back a French film student
named Yannick felt like Disney had just
pulled the rug out from underneath him
in 2006 three years before Disney
released up Yannick produced a short
film called above than beyond and up was
eerily similar to Yannick short for
starters both the movie and the short
start an elderly person who was living
alone in their longtime home secondly
both protagonists were being hassled by
businessmen to sell their houses and so
both characters chose to bring their
homes to the sky where they could find
some well-deserved peace there were some
differences though like the fact that
Yannick short starred an elderly woman
whereas Disney's showcased a grumpy
widow named Carl Fredricksen oh and
let's not forget about how Disney's Carl
whisked his house up up and away using
hundreds of balloons while yeah mix
character used a single hot-air balloon
let me know if you were thinking of
giving Disney the benefit of the doubt
think again cuz this next one is too
close for comfort
Disney release the Lion King back in
1994 and everything from its storyline
and animation to its characters and
songs were amazing but to some people
the Lion King came across as an obvious
ripoff of the Japanese film Kimba the
White Lion this movie which is based off
a manga series by Osamu Tezuka first
aired in 1965 decades before the Lion
King hit the big screen
although disney swears that the
inspiration for the Lion King derives
from Shakespeare's Hamlet the semblance
between both movies is far too uncanny
to be a coincidence we mean come on
Simba and Kimba what are the odds of
that and don't get us started on scar
and how he nears the evil lion cloth
down to the scratch on his eyelid when
placed side by side it's hard to believe
that Disney didn't use Kimba the White
Lion as a premise for the film time out
let me get this straight
much like Denis Daniels Gary Goldman
attempted to sue Disney for stealing his
idea and designs only to be met by
Disney's ironclad team of lawyers Gary a
veteran screenwriter filed a lawsuit
against Disney in 2017 accusing them of
stealing his idea for Zootopia although
Gary never released a movie with a
similar basis he did pitch the film to
Disney a handful of times between 2000
and 2009 only to be rejected tenfold so
you can imagine his surprise when
Zootopia was released especially since
he allegedly came up with the title for
the movie
unfortunately for Gary his case was
thrown out by the judge who said that
there were more differences than
similarities between his version and
Disney's however fans cannot deny that
Gary sketches do share many similarities
with the characters Disney would go on
to include in their film it looks like
Disney knows a thing or two about taking
someone's original idea revamping it
using it and getting away with it I'm
here to
some questions about a case what
happened meter maid did someone steal a
traffic home it wasn't me
in 2008 Disney Pixar released the movie
wall-e which follows a waste collector
drone who is tasked with cleaning up the
planet the movie takes place in the
distant future and was created by Andrew
Stanton an animators Brett Parker and
Wendell lead it was all fun and games
until Disney was once again accused of
stealing their designs from the 1986
sci-fi comedy short circuit although we
enter denied using short circuits
protagonist Johnny Five as inspiration
for wall-e
both robots bear a striking resemblance
to each other
for this reason Andrew Stanton has been
asked about this mishap on multiple
occasions and although he has admitted
to having watched the short circuit film
at least once he denies having borrowed
any of its designs
Andrew confess that he could have
subconsciously used Johnny Five as
inspiration for wall-e but has denied
any ill intent or plagiarism but their
similarities are too great to deny suing
Disney for copyright claims isn't an
easy or wise thing to do and no one
knows this better than French writer
Frank law kavas who believes that Disney
stole his idea and used it to create the
box-office blowout finding Nemo
according to Franck he first pitched the
idea to Disney in 1995 however it was
rejected which led him to turn his movie
idea into a children's book which he
then published in 2003 during this time
Disney was hard at work creating Finding
Nemo which takes a page out of Frank's
book parrot the clownfish Frank would
attempt to sue Disney for copying his
main character as well as another
character a lobster who is obsessed with
cleanliness although Frank did his best
to plead his case Disney lawyers were
quick to dismiss him what's worse is
that they countersued the author for
damages and legal fees and won in the
end Frank lost the court case and had to
pay Disney close to $100,000 it wasn't
for you I never would have even made
here so thank you Disney has a team of
excellent writers and producers who go
the extra mile to create amazing films
however there is one writer who has a
bad reputation of stealing the ideas of
employees and being an all-around credit
hog we're talking about John Lasseter of
course John has been accused of stealing
ideas for as long as he's been at Disney
well one of his former employees Jorgen
Clube Ian stated that he pitched the
idea to create a film about talking cars
to Jon and was never credited what's
worse is that Jorgen was removed from
the project right before it became a
huge franchise on top of allegedly
stealing his idea cars also seems to be
a direct ripoff of the 1991 film doc
Hollywood both movies share the same
narrative with the exception of Disney's
protagonists being a talking car
it's too close to call it's no secret
that Disney draws inspiration from
classic fairytales to create some of
their most successful movies however
Disney has gotten away with this because
the original authors are no longer
around to file copyright lawsuits
against them although it's normal to
gain inspiration from classic works of
art Disney's history points towards
recycling ideas instead of generating
new ones in 1998 Disney Pixar released a
bug's life around the same time as
DreamWorks and both movies are so alike
that they often sparked debate so how
did two different production companies
come up with the exact same premise for
a movie well the original idea was
pitched by an existing dizzy employee
however it was former Disney chairman
Jeffrey Katzenberg's idea to ask
employees for these pitches so when he
left his knee to start DreamWorks he
took the idea with him but this didn't
fly with John Lasseter who despite
refusing the original pitch chose to
push forward with the film after
Jeffrey's departure Disney's film has
since been coined a bug fly due to the
sketchiness of its origins
[Music]
it's one thing to steal ideas from other
people but a whole other thing to steal
ideas from ones past work for the first
time in Disney history musicians and
writers Alan Menken and Howard Ashman
admitted that they had recycled songs
and ideas from some of their previous
projects Ellen and Howard worked
together to compose the soundtrack for
the 1986 film Little Shop of Horrors
then years later they were hired by
Disney to work on a handful of
Renaissance era Disney movies like The
Little Mermaid Allen and Howard created
the acclaimed song part of your world
and it is one of the most beloved songs
in Disney history however it was quickly
revealed that part of your world for one
too many similarities to the song
something that's green from Little Shop
of Horrors both these musical hits have
similar lyrics structures and melodies
in fact they're pretty much identical
[Music]
Disney's Aladdin has been a hit ever
since it hit the big screen in 1992
although Disney revealed that they
loosely based Aladdin on the 1940
version of The Thief of Bagdad it seems
as though they used more than just one
film as inspiration it didn't take long
for viewers to point out that Aladdin
was a mirror image of the unfinished
animated film the thief and the cobbler
which had been in development for over
30 years
clearly Jafar and Genie are an
amalgamation of the original projects
antagonists zigzag but if there's one
thing that cements Disney's plagiarism
its the fact that the production company
hired several of the animators who had
been working on the thief and the
cobbler I have power over people though
they may appear come today it comes as
no surprise that Walt Disney himself has
been accused of stealing ideas in the
past after all his predecessors would go
on to adopt a similar method when
scouring for new ideas
according to NY Post Walt Disney claims
that the idea for Mickey Mouse one day
popped into his head while riding the
train but his former friend an animator
I worked tells a very different story as
it turns out
but came up with the design for Mickey
Mouse but was never credited as the sole
creator he first brought Mickey to life
in the animated short plane crazy in
1928
however Walt Disney would go on to take
his design and create dozens of Mickey
Mouse movies and TV shows while posing
as his inventor
are you surprised to find out that
Disney doesn't have the cleanest track
record do you think that they actually
stole these ideas sound off in the
comments and thanks for watching for
more fun videos be sure to LIKE and
subscribe we'll see you next time on the
things
you